pascal alors lui il a été moins généreux
star de la star ac mais il ya des plus
connus je vais vous dire quelque chose
passe quelque chose qui sont pas moi
j'ai été pendus c'est vrai qu'au décès
de mon père je vais vous dire je devais
185000 aux impôts alors si j'ai perdu
mon contrat tf1 à un moment ce que j'ai
été salarié de tf1 en tant qu'animateur
j'avais cinq balles par mois j'ai perdu
mon contrat tf1 je devais 185 1000 euros
par chance mon père m'avait fait acheter
un terrain j'ai pu redémarrer les
redémarrer à zéro
et puis j'ai eu un bas d'il ya huit ans
je n'avais rien je pense que les gens
aussi les stars comme on dit il faut pas
avoir peur de redémarrer de se dire mais
je fais de la télé
qu'est ce que je sais faire d'autre j'ai
ouvert un petit resto ça a moyennement
marché j'ai vendu j'ai fait serveur dans
un restaurant les gens toute la journée
vous dise ah ça vous mène là la télé les
gens sont des connards raynaud c'est
vrai j'étais un an et demi au restaurant
du golf de chantaco qui m'a pris et
après cyril tu m'as pris et c'est pour
ça je te le dis et je le dis avec
émotion parce que ça n'a pas été facile
et je suis passé par des moments hyper
dur et jeu mais j'ai quand même eu la
chance de delphine qui s'occupait de mes
enfants j'ai galéré à payer mon loyer
j'en ai chié mais je veux dire un truc
c'est pas parce qu'on fait de la télé on
peut pas être boulanger ou autres parce
que les gens là reconnaissait n'y
arrivait pas quand il faut bouffer c'est
bien il faut bouffer mais que ce soit
serveurs électricien gorges il n'ya pas
de sot métier il faut s'adapter
donc moi ces gens là au bout d'un moment
et je les plains pas passifs avant les
couilles de dire eh ben il faut faire
autre chose et ça redémarrera est la
preuve
c'est vrai j'ai redémarré ses murs mais
si on se bat on peut y arriver
voilà jean pascal c'est non mais c'est
dingue ce que vous dites moi ce qui ce
qui m'a ce qui m'a marqué c'est fastoche
vous étiez serveurs et donc là les gens
n'arrêtaient pas de vous dire mais
qu'est ce tu fais en fait ça a dû vous
des primeurs à fou oui parce que c'est
au moment où j'ai divorcé de sas était
compétitive et les gens et les gens ils
vous démonte
mais même aujourd'hui c'est pas le truc
fastoche tu bois c'est quand tu
m'appeler bien faire là qu'il a
maintenant
bavard mais je sais mais c'est une
chance que tu vois bien je dis je
remercie donc je veux dire quand on se
bat on peut toujours y arriver voilà je
ne suis pas du genre j'aime pas je
n'aime pas ce chalet ou quoi mais quand
on veut se bouger le cul bon on peut
toujours essayer d'arriver il faut pas
écouter désormais visé ou à regarder où
ça mène la télé tout ça en rigolant avec
ses sacs et ses carrés vip fauchant